der fliegerorst pumowski in langen
Lebern in Niederösterreich wird weiter
ausgebaut für die dort stationierten
black HAW Helikopter wird unter anderem
eine neue Werkstätte samt Lager und eine
Wartungs und Lackierbox
benötigt die Werkstätte mit angrenzenden
Lager wird eine Nutzfläche von ca 1400
die Wartungs und Lackierbox von ca 1000
quadr aufweisen ein weiterer wichtiger
Schritt auf unserer Mission vorwärts
hier in langen Lebern wird nicht zuletzt
aufgrund zzlicher Beschaffungen von
Hubschraubern insbesondere weiterer
black HAW ein neues Werkstättengebäude
eine Lackierbox und so weiter errichtet
ein wichtiger Schritt für die
luftstreckräfte für das gesamte
Bundesheer rund 15 Millionen Euro werden
dafür in den Fliegerhorst investiert
fertig gestellt soll das Projekt im Juni
sein